comme une carapace le solide échafaudage
va permettre aux restaurateurs de sauver
des outrages du temps cette chapelle que
les touristes du bout du monde viennent
admirer mais avant de restaurer il faut
bien comprendre comment elle a été
construite c'était il ya plus de 65 ans
pour les vitrages le corbusier a utilisé
plusieurs techniques à chaud ou à froid
aujourd'hui les experts du patrimoine
mène l enquête je regarde si s'il ya
deux couches a priori il y aurait deux
couches l'original de le corbusier et et
une retouche par dessus et l'idée c'est
de savoir où est ce que je vais prélevé
selon si je veux caractérisé le la
technique originale ou houle europe 1 de
retour dans son laboratoire de marseille
ce chimiste analysera ce minuscule
échantillon de peinture et la peinture
d'origine de le corbusier si on pouvait
l'identifier ce serait vraiment
extrêmement intéressant et puis essayer
d'identifier les différentes peintures
de restauration de retouche qui ont été
appliqués et à partir de là en fait ces
éléments là vont nous permettre
d'établir le protocole pour la future
restauration
à l'extérieur ce sont des spécialistes
des bétons qui ausculte les murs des
choses qu'il faut conserver parce que ça
c'est amélie mais tout à ça ce que ça
faut pas venir nous prendre dépit des
remèdes et inique cailloux on ad on a du
bullage donc il ya un gros travail à
faire sur sur la réparation le travail
qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est de voir la
réalité dans l'opération construction du
comportement des matériaux comment ils
ont comment il se comporte et quand on
les a fabriquées et puis comment ils
réagissent dans la durée le corbusier et
son collaborateur d'andré maisonnier
était toute à leur chantier du moment
ils n'ont pas laissé d'indications pour
les restaurations des siècles à venir en
aide quand même des archives par rapport
à à la conception et dans certains cas
aussi des documents d attachement des
documents des plans d'exécution ce qu'on
appelle des documents des entreprises et
tout ça c'était un souhait de le
corbusier de le conserver pour c'est
pour ça qu'il a créé aussi sa fondation
très bientôt les visiteurs auront eux
aussi accès à une partie des
échafaudages leur guide conférencier
leur raconteront les résultats de toutes
ces enquêtes inédites